you're a good job a real lion Kancha
you survived yes I survived good luck
with that
my turn
why are you doing this because it's time
for you to die
[Music]
on this planet
Ankush or is dead I'm cyborg superman
hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my cyborg Superman comics vs. TV show
vs. movies video so there's been a bunch
of different versions of the character
so I'm gonna start with comics then
we'll work our way to the TV show so the
cool thing about cyborg superman is you
know most of my memories of him as a
child were from the reign of the
Superman era you know after they killed
Superman off in the comics big big event
they debuted all these pretenders to the
throne amongst them was the Hank Henshaw
cyborg Superman but the big twist is
that you didn't learn that cyborg
superman was evil till much much later
in that storyline you only knew him as
the cyborg superman you didn't know he
was secretly hank henshaw so the funny
thing about hank henshaw is he was
created as a bit of a riff kind of a
joke on Fantastic Four's origin story
family and friends on a mission in outer
space for Lex Corp get hit by solar
radiation and it has all kinds of crazy
stuff to their biology and eventually
hank henshaw ends up uploading his mind
to a computer so he becomes artificial
intelligence all the weird stuff that
happens to his crew because of the solar
radiation ends up being this big runnin
with Superman so eventually he's able to
rescue his wife but when he appears to
her as this artificial intelligence you
know it's like this cobbled together
machinery she flips commit suicide and
hank henshaw
vows revenge against superman blaming
him for all the problems they've had so
before Superman could take him down he
transmits his intelligence to Superman's
pod takes off into outer space for parts
unknown never to be heard from again
till the reign of the Superman storyline
so while in outer space eventually he
hatches this plan with Mongol on war
world to take down Superman and it
becomes like this big arc that ropes
ain't Green Lantern and spun into a big
Green Lantern Hal Jordans storyline
where he was possessed by parallax so
eventually he winds up on apocalypse
which is really fun storyline later you
know most people remember him from the
war of light because he became part of
the Sinestro Corps he had taken over the
Manhunters so basically like the
Manhunters became a tool of the Sinestro
Corps so if you haven't read it but you
like you've seen pictures of him where
the lantern rings like these really
badass art that's from Geoff Johns
Sinestro Corps storyline so he's a super
badass character but he actually became
more of like a Green Lantern character
eventually in the comics that was what
that Manhunter storyline was and then
the real twist becomes this is kind of
sad he just wants to die but you know
because of the way his artificial
intelligence is consciousness works
he just keeps surviving even though he
does not want to live anymore so he
helps out the anti-monitor in exchange
for the anti-monitor killing him that
doesn't go down very well
later he tries to get Necron to kill him
during blackest night still can't get
him to do that and then becomes a
prisoner of STAR Labs before the big new
52 reboot so recently in the new
Supergirl rebirth comic a version of
cyborg superman surfaces but it's
actually Zoe L her father and it's a bit
of a smaller story like it's not quite
as crazy and sprawling as the death and
return of Superman but it becomes more
of a storyline of her sacrificing her
humanity in order to get back her family
she's a slightly different spin on the
character you know like very different
from the Hank Henshaw cyborg superman in
the reason he kept coming back for
Superman but thus far the closest thing
we've seen to cyborg superman in the
movies is actually the animated movie
Superman doomsday where Lex creates a
clone but it's like an amalgam of
Superboy Conner Kent in cyborg superman
in the comics so it's not true cyborg
Superman but I definitely think they
could use the character in the DC
extended universe eventually they're
working on the second Man of Steel movie
it's still a long ways off I mean it's
gonna be a long time before we see it
but as a Superman villain he's actually
a pretty solid pick it's a huge middle
finger to Superman so I could totally
see lex luthor trying to clone Superman
in some way or create an artificial
Superman just something really evil that
walks around wearing his face but now to
explain the TV show version because they
are doing hank henshaw cyborg superman
but it's a bit of a twist because he
wears the same face as martian manhunter
so he's more of a cyborg green Martian
but he does have some of Cara's DNA so
he looks more like comic book cyborg
Superman but it's more of a Martian
Manhunter twist on it but because of
that I don't think that he'll be wearing
the S you know
not gonna be straight-up comic-book
cyborg Superman so it is a vast
departure in that sense but he is using
the fortress of solitude with Kara's DNA
so he's slightly more important for
martian manhunter character development
at this point than he is for Kara's
character development but that just
remains to be seen but here's my
question for you guys how do you want
them to use the character in the new DC
live-action movies if they wanted to do
a Superman clone they've kind of already
done a Kryptonian amalgam clone that was
kind of what doomsday was so I'm not
expecting them to do Superboy anytime
soon like Conner Kent but they could do
a version where they combine storylines
like that in the future if they want to
get really crazy with Superman villains
in the movies they would probably do
parasite or they might even just use
some of the forces of apocalypse like
there are a bunch of people that won't
be in the Justice League movie that they
can just pull off the bench if you're
looking for a really good cyborg
superman comic book story to read I
would recommend just the reign of the
Superman arc through the destruction of
coast city and then later The Revenge of
the Green Lantern so like cyborg
superman versus the Green Lantern Corps
in the Sinestro Corps award which is an
amazing Green Lantern storyline both
solid picks so what's gonna happen next
is there's new flash tomorrow
kill the frost so be sure to subscribe
to get that video there is a new round
of the DC giveaway - all you have to do
to enter that is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video some of
you've also been asking for a Black
Panther video they announced a whole
bunch of the cast so I might do a video
for that before I post my flash video so
whole bunch of stuff happening this week
happy Thanksgiving everybody that
celebrates Thanksgiving this week -
where you guys wait - that's a post you
can click here for like the big
crossover trailer again and you can
click here to watch the killer frost
flash trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight